amico indovina cosa sto mangiando una
banana no uno yogurt con il semi di
girasole quelli di anne taro è tanta
bene invece di deliziarci con la sigla
di antara giochiamo in cooperativa forza
amico vieni ciao sono dietro ciao amico
e non puoi perché è stata i progressi
ogni volta che giochiamo capito
ogni volta che ti aspetta che con
l'audio madonna mi sto sorridendo le
orecchie non capisco niente dobbiamo
andare dove ci porta dove doveva andare
e non lo so che cosa stai facendo gli
doni qua selezione a livello e quindi
perche i vai vai vai parare perfetto
raccogliere con i massi guai la tua
camera idiota no questa è la mia è una
donna
l'arancione brutto daltonico o no money
no basta
ma noi l'abbiamo già fatto no aspetta
l'abbiamo già fatto questa e benzina io
mi da sei facce rifà cosa stai facendo
poteva fare questa cosa ti prego
bellissima
cosa sta dicendo questo sono esplosi ha
già fatto esplodere lei brutta stronza
maledetta ma perché po colpa tua perché
non solo fredda come un robot ma no mi
stai prendendo per il culo cioè noi
abbiamo fatto
basta
basta dai andiamo facciamo li facciamo
lì che siamo forti
allora prendi faccio io faccio io lascia
perdere definito faccio io ok
prendi cosa lo metti su aiuto è molto
giù molto dice se salta la ti fa una
roba vieni qua quindi quando vieni qui
vieni qua tu per cortesia
già se riesco subito ok ok ok allora ci
avevi ragione per una volta salvi
ragione
questo è complicato da lo giuro sai che
non non è amico viene incendi
guardala va dai 100 e cose si sparava li
dovete usare i sali mai
ok perfetto grazie un'ora e mezza per
questa falsità cagata degli stalli sud
sai su permesso un amara per fare una
cagata niente non ce la faremo perché
pietro alle mani nel culo ok e cosa devo
fare qua già effetto è lo so che volevi
fare una cagata amatelo evitata 3 l'una
o niente a si esce se senza perfetto
vajassa importa tu adesso vai che tripli
infatti e basket non stava bene abbiamo
fatto il mega livello finale possiamo
fare anche questo
credo che qua ci voglia devi carmelo
tugluk qua vieni guardami kagami
cioè io se ti faccio tutto io vice ue
sta in loop bye bye bye li stai così
bambini bene non so lo so che stai per
lui ma sai che negli occhi non sapete
quando chiudi gli occhi non guardare lo
schermo faccio io tanto non serve ma
perché non riesce a stare fermo no
secondi con il suo talk show decreti
mediamente sono scemo io perfetto che ho
lanciato ti ho fatto anche male il che
mila anche di soddisfazione ma mi sa che
lo devi fare tu adesso vai
dopo un po bene però c'è
addio grazie perfetto sei stato bravo
meglio di me perché a me non è una legge
che è stata prima tra sentirsi fruttare
vederci si materializzarono i tre
secondi non so quale peggio aiuto ma si
sta roba
hai una minima idea di che cosa dovremmo
fare qua pronto dall'altra porto ma non
posso mica mica salta ma lo vedi che sei
un idiota di quelli che fa veramente
schifo a vari fatto apposta
pensavo che non lo sa perché ecco ecco
vedo vedo vedo bene ci metti un secondo
la quale ne va l'altra non e non sale
neanche sulle neanche le scale sa che
non aspetta
mi sono ricordato adesso che se passi
sugli oggetti attraverso il portale si
smaterializza la faccio al lupo va bene
ma tu sei niente non finiremo maisto
livello impossibile ma schiaccia subito
non schiaccia subito che gol chiaro la
digno devi andare di sopra tu e io ti
devo passare questo dovevo passare
proprio ok perfetto
perfetto allora vai a metterlo siamo
così allora dobbiamo amina via il
portale per favore
ma i pazzi o le ci abbiamo messo un'ora
e mezza per fa anche questa ma ci abbia
fatto mi chiamo solo dobbiamo fare
insieme divertente pieni pirla non credo
ci serva molto vieni qua che entra nel
loop ma ha fatto bene ad altre la trovai
poi schiaccia piace scaccia porca vacca
bravo bravo ce l'hai fatta sei fatto ci
hai fatto sei fatta seif ha fatto sì una
schiacciata di tutti di palla i testi di
giocoleria ne bastava una critica la
mente io e mia la palla e va bene perché
non possiamo giocare a starhub anche
nella vita reale godrej un sacco vederti
così stai così perfetto comico affetto
ma credo che sarà funzioni anche se lo
faccio io difficile questo edificio il
suo livello
d'amico che fisco madonna chiamale che
pedate
mi sa che dovevamo fare una roba un po
congiunta aspetta un po devi boh non lo
so perché vedo che ci sono schiantati
sud a noi guarda vieni tramiti puoi
portare lì lo vedi ok da parte o
dall'altra va il fallo bike effetto ok
qua non so cosa serva a noi basta fare
così vai barba fai fai fai
vai buttati tu ci sei arrivato io come
sappiamo dirvi piazzarmi portali to peer
la se non arrivo io e non posso da
questa parte non è sì che poi come circa
in piazza come già è vero ma devi
piazzarlo qua hanno effettivamente però
come cambiamo gioco te lo giuro
la pallida idea e non si vola cos'è
cos'è che siamo scemi
era una creato incredibile era una
cagata incredibile è la cosa più stupida
che abbia mai visto
certo questo e dopo sta roba da tornerà
neanche la fine del livello è la sola
parte c'è la di un'ora per fare una cosa
del da criceti delle cavie siamo stupidi
come la morte mamma mia
l'università proprio non era un'opzione
nelle nostre vite ai macelli
20 gr e non mi spiegate perchè devi fare
quello che hai fatto ti schiaccia ma ci
piace per accendere lo abbiamo già vedo
se mangiato tutto va bene a che cosa
serve al cubo non ne ho idea se la porta
aperta
è vero bravo non ci hanno pensato bravo
pietro sì magari di essere così chiuso
qui dentro io ok allora il culo ce
l'abbiamo
resta qua per te poker e poi ora spara
spara i due portali esterni dentro stai
lì ok state di star lì perché sono tesi
dematerializza arrivo faccio le cose
giuste arrivi passa che viene anche tu e
allora è effettivamente quello potrebbe
essere un problema non certo come cvd
per caso no sì mi metti me lo dai
ciò che è successo ac vedere la
videocamera sta imballando lo sapete con
il creato esaltano il sud come gli
imbecilli dopo aver conseguito il minimo
pietro ma vere
no non dai nel mio nel mio ascensore
sembra con la una cosa per la moglie
dire ok dovremmo avere finito il set di
livelli questo era l'ultimo in teoria
che era un casino incredibile prove
buona quantità guarda quanti passi
faccio io quanto non fa un cazzo tu cosa
c'era scritto che ho fatto 9 mila passi
to 3000 ti muovi la metà terzo di m
vieni qua veloce ma cosa facciamo questi
ci mancano sette livelli veloce acqua e
ha il potere di schiacciare la persona
che sa fare le cose è ovviamente quella
persona nei coppa entra entra e non ti
schiaccerà te lo prometto non ti
schiaccerà devi andare fatto non ti
schiaccia te lo prometto davvero ma
perché tutto dritto dritto dritto
vai crea
si no ok niente niente si schiaccia ti
giuro che l'unica roba che devi fare la
stare fermo là dentro non dovevi fare
nient'altro che stare fermo ci si
schiacciano ho sbagliato ma per farceli
dai dopo prenderlo portarlo da te lo
sapevo bene che no vabbè io non ho
veramente però c'è tanto non centro a
cosa cazzo farlo a fare cene 78 so che è
così non c'è neanche bisogno mi stupì
non mi incazzo neanche più
non mi incazzo neanche proprio guarda un
demente del porca eva che mai della
guardai ok
vai finiremo prima di domani si no il
cubo è appunto inizia
io non ce la faccio c'era che non ce la
faccio la depressione corpo forse non ti
ammazzo e solo perché voglio finire il
livello non perché devo fare altra roba
e cioè perché per se dipendesse da me
guarda ma è importante che pagava sì sì
sì certo
grazie allora mettilo dove dobbiamo
tagliate male porca eva mettilo quinnell
ok fatto cose però va bene vieni vai
ragazzi questo primo episodio dire che
poco prima il secondo in sommando
contare davvero che vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi consenso che piacere momento mi
piace anche ad essere tutte le sezioni
sono saliti si scateni ci rivediamo il
prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]